he is the oscar-winning star of crazy
heart the big lebowski a million other
great ones and the upcoming bad times at
the El Royale
his documentary living in the futures
past opens today please welcome Jeff
Bridges
[Applause]
now they're standing up well I know you
don't come here unless you have
something on your mind a busy guy in a
private guy and I appreciate that but
it's always something important and I
know it's the environment because I
watched your documentary twice it's
fantastic and I've heard you talk about
it a little I know you got your interest
in the environment first from your
father because you did I used to watch
that show Sea Hunt yeah
Sea Hunt before that show and he got so
involved with well the health of the sea
and how important it was and that he
brought the whole family yeah and and
this is about the environment but it's
it's different in the sense that you're
trying to find out how can we be at such
a dire place and still not have reacted
why are we hardwired human yeah to not
react to a slow-moving crisis I don't
think so I think you know we're
hardwired to breathe and you know grow
fingernails and beat our hearts and
stuff like that but being hardwired to
fail I don't think that's really in our
cars but don't we react only to things
that are about I mean doesn't the
history of our environmental reactions
bear this out we react only to things
that are immediate threats that's the
problem
yeah well the frog in the pod yeah I
just I just got an immediate threat you
know I was rescued by a helicopter but
the debris flow in Santa Barbara where
you know 22 people were killed just
reflow debris flow this is due to the
among the fire there was a huge fire the
thomas fire in santa barbara
oh yeah and all the foliage was burned
and here comes the debris flow the whole
hillside where you know bowie and i saw
your house in our house yeah but that
that was after the movie was made you
know but they brought it it brought it
all home
but we'd you know we weren't thinking
about making this movie we didn't want
to do a doom and gloom kind of thing
right enough movies about that we didn't
want to downplay the seriousness of our
situation but we wanted to shed you know
new light on on
thing and we thought yeah let's let's do
something that's gonna flip the the hood
up and examine what's making us tick as
a species and why we are behaving the
way we are in front of this enormous
challenge we have so why haven't we done
more well you know to look that far in
the in the future it's not that's not
what we're really wired for you know one
of my you know it's it's it's such a
tendency to kind of throw up your hands
I know my own cynicism with this whole
thing you know when you think of the you
know the politicians and the news and
you know we often think well our
politicians are gonna save us you know
it's gonna kind of trickle down but we
can't wait for these guys to you know
stand the scientific eye well I did I
can't agree with that because I think
the only people who can solve this are
is government I don't think this is like
World War two we're not gonna yes people
can save ten and ration but they're not
going to defeat Hitler it's going to
take the government to tell people we
have a carbon they definitely have a
role but we have a role as individuals
not only in voting that's very important
and to vote with people who are in
alignment with your thinking but here I
meant you go but let me let me just can
I say my thing
no a that's don't say works here's the
deal this is what I think about just
personal responsibility one of my heroes
is Bucky fuller you know but Miller yeah
yeah his most amazing invention was the
geodesic dome right but he made a
wonderful observation with the huge
ocean-going tankers that we say and he
said the the engineers were quite
challenged by trying to get this huge
rudder to turn this big ship it took too
much energy to turn that huge rudder it
had to be too big so they came up with a
beautiful elegant solution let's put a
little rudder on that big runner and
that little rudder will turn the big
rudder the big
it turns the ship and that little run is
called a trim tab and Bucky said this is
a great metaphor for how the individual
is connected to society you know we
think open just this one little
individual but we're connected now I'm
connected to you I know but but but the
little rudder isn't doing that it's
buying an SUV well well that's what this
is what we want this is what the movie
is encouraging people to do I know but
people don't give a [ __ ] you know
because I mean that and that's the
problem is that if the government
doesn't make all of us do what people
look like one of the first people to
have a Prius yeah and and you know after
why you look around is like nobody else
is helping why am i driving this shitty
little thing why am i busting my balls
and everybody else is and if we've all
decided we're gonna go over the Grand
Canyon let's just hold hands and go but
I'm not gonna be the one to deprive
myself of everybody doesn't including
younger people who have more at stake
tonight well I've had my fun with the
air you throw your hands up and you say
no not at all not at all but I'm just
saying I think it has to be electing
politicians who will make that yes I'm
sure that can't be all it is no yeah but
the vision is all of us all of us are
true tabs man but it's connected we can
do you connect ourselves to
organizations care a good hippie